hallo mein Name ist Luca
und meine Damen und Herren diesen Satz
habt ihr tatsächlich seit drei Wochen
nicht gehört
weil ich so lange nichts mehr
hochgeladen habe hier auf meinem Youtube
Kanal
und in den letzten Tagen ist mir einfach
ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen
die Decke auf dem Kopf gefallen
ich habe mir seit Silvester extrem viele
Gedanken gemacht sehr viel nachgedacht
sehr viel mich auch abgelenkt mit
Freunden unternommen und
schlussendlich jetzt in den letzten
Tagen so ein bisschen realisiert dass
bei mir persönlich die Luft einfach so
ein bisschen raus ist
eigentlich wollte ich dieses Video hier
auch schon viel früher hochladen
jedoch
ja es ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
schwer gefallen ja
ihr merkt auch jetzt glaube ich gerade
dass ich ja hier während der Aufnahme
schon sehr am schwitzen bin
aber bitte reden oder ich mache ein
Video meine Augen auch ein bisschen rot
sind aber ich habe vorhin vor der
Aufnahme auch krank geheult
so oder so will ich euch jetzt aber
nicht noch weiter auf die Folter spannen
ich will jetzt nicht noch länger um den
heißen Brei rum reden ich habe auch hier
keine Werbung auf dem Video drauf das
heißt ich verdiene mit diesem Video
nicht ich habe auch direkt die
Bewertungen und die Kommentare alles
deaktiviert damit jetzt nicht
wildgerüchte gestreut werden was genau
hier irgendwie der Grund ist
allerdings sieht es ja eh schon im Titel
eingeblendet ich hänge tatsächlich meine
Karriere an den Nagel
[Musik]
denn ich hör auf mit YouTube
Livestreams meine Damen und die kamen
nämlich sonst mal auf meinen zweitkanal
lukschuh allerdings werde ich die jetzt
auf Twitch machen ihr findet ein Link
und in der Videobeschreibung
eingeblendet Twitch Laser Luca als ich
da bin tatsächlich auch gleich um 16 Uhr
live mit Sandra sind wir auf einer
Bootsmesse für so Superreiche Yachten
und machen dann Wissenschaftler schaltet
gerne ein allerdings mache ich dieses
Video hier nicht nur um Promo für meinen
Twitch Account zu machen und zu sagen
dass ich ab jetzt ziemlich viel
Livestream werde weil ich da irgendwie
extrem Lust drauf habe und generelle
Social Media einfach dafür da dass man
das macht worauf man Lust hat und das
habe ich schon vor zwei Jahren gemacht
als ich plötzlich wieder mit Minecraft
angefangen habe wo niemand gespielt hat
spielt irgendwie jeder Minecraft ne
lange Rede kurzer Sinn ich habe auf
jeden Fall wieder richtig Bock durch zu
starten nach meiner dreiwöchigen Pause
hier es werden daily Uploads kommen auf
einen zweitkanal mit reactions Games etc
es werden auch wieder fast da die Ablauf
kommen auf meinem Hauptkanal hier mit
Reallife Videos mit Vlogs mit challenges
etc pp und halt auch noch Livestreams
auf Twitch ich bin wie gesagt jetzt
gleich live um 16 Uhr schaltet gerne ein
um 16 Uhr
twitch.tv/laser Luca links und in der
Videobeschreibung ciao
so schnell werdet ihr mich nicht los